nous voici de nouveau parmi vous pour
poursuivre l'émission en direct de
concurrentes sont encore en course mais
une seule va bientôt épouser un
millionnaire j'ai décidé d'épouser
prendre vie que ressentons quand on est
devenu comme vous un héros national ne
suis pas un héros je n'ai fait que ce
que tout le monde aurait fait dans ces
circonstances voir que la plupart des
gens se seraient enfuis ce qu'il s'est
passé dans votre émission est un vrai
désastre
mais légalement ni le groupe wpc ni les
producteurs ne peuvent être tenus
responsables donc si nous avions une
émission en direct des gens comme était
un suicide
vous ne serez pas en valois ras-le-bol
d'exploiter les gens pour faire de
l'audience
si effectivement les gens meurent je
veux tu meurs pour une bonne présence
band and en sac
yab 3
ce que vous allez voir ce soir est
différent de tout ce que vous avez vu à
la télévision vous serez probablement
choqué
sarah hickey ne pourra plus avoir de
nouvelles vies mais sa fille pourrait
vous n'avez qu'une chose à faire c'est
poté on a offert 300 mille dollars à ses
deux filles
tout le monde à la télé mais pas riche
et beau et ne vit pas rêve américain ce
sont des gens comme nous ils sont
pauvres et sans espoir coûté jeunes
familles fait bientôt perdre ma maison
je ferai tout ce que vous demandez vous
comprenez ce débat soit
[Musique]
m
merci d'avoir regardé vous allez mourir
ce soir la vie est précieuse
rivella pleinement
[Musique]